[Music]
what's better than your favorite
superhero is combined with some
absolutely adorable kittens we don't
think that there's anything better than
that so if you've ever wondered what
spider-man would look like in real life
as a cat make sure to stick around until
the end of the video don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and give this video a big
thumbs up now join us as we take a look
at 15 superheroes in real life as cats
the Hulk this superhero goes by many
names
Joe Fixit the crusher and even the world
breaker it's the gentle giant himself
the Incredible Hulk
once an incredible scientist Bruce
banners life changed forever when he was
exposed to a powerful blast from a gamma
ray from then on he was able to harness
the power of anger to transform himself
into one of the most epic superheroes
out there Marvel gave this man the power
of super strength to take on his foes he
uses this power to Hulk smash anything
in his path jump from building to
building and keep the ones he loves most
safe from wrongdoers and we were beyond
excited to find this kitty cat version
of the Hulk this little kitty has a
brilliant costume complete with tiny
muscles and the Hulk's signature blue
shorts this cat's owner even built a
miniature city for the Hulk to smash
through it's pretty amazing right Loki
although Loki is one of the lesser known
superheroes on this list that doesn't
make him any less fascinating the story
of Loki has its roots in ancient
mythology in fact the character of Loki
was actually based on a Norse
mythological deity of the same name
sound familiar that's right
Loki is actually the adoptive brother of
our other Norse hero Thorpe although
Loki is often depicted as a supervillain
we like to think of him as a superhero
that's just lost his way like any
superhero he's got some pretty
incredible powers these powers include
astral projection flight and even
teleportation oh and did we mention his
gigantic horns well you definitely can't
miss the horns on our little Loki Kitty
here since they're nearly as big as his
body these horns combined with Loki's
trademark blue cape make this costume
incredibly realistic now let's give this
cat some space he's obviously pondering
something pretty deep
Deadpool okay we know what you're
thinking
another antihero really well you better
believe we couldn't skip one of our
all-time favorite heroes Deadpool
compared
many other superheroes Deadpool is
relatively new did you know that he's
only been around since the 90s despite
his short time in the Marvel Universe
Deadpool became an instant sensation
thanks to his sassy humor and unique way
of interacting with the audience he was
so popular in fact that he actually
received his own feature film in 2016
with such a well liked character it's no
surprise that someone decided to dress
their cat up in His image and boy does
this Kitty look fierce the costume is
incredibly OnPoint with a classic
Deadpool belt and even the anti-heroes
faithful swords where do you even find
sorts that small is there a small sword
store we don't know about
either way this outfit is definitely
hard to beat Nick Fury is he a secret
agent a spy or superhero well he's all
three that's right Nick Fury originally
started out as a CIA operative when the
character debuted in 1965 a few years
later he had turned into the world's
sneakiest spy not long after that he was
promoted to the ranks of superhero using
his strategy and combat expertise to
fight crime this character became so
popular that they actually gave him his
own television movie in 1998 and who
played this highly skilled superhero in
the movie
none other than samuel l.jackson who
starred in other movies like snakes on a
plane and xxx return of xander cage if
imitation is the highest form of
flattery Nick Fury would certainly be
blushing to see this cat dressed up as
his character with a popped black collar
and Fury's recognizable eyepatch this
costume is a perfect match
excuse the pun but it seems like we
might as well call this cat Nick furry
the Red Lantern well you may have heard
of DC's famed superhero the Green
Lantern you may not have heard of the
lesser-known antihero the Red Lantern
this character is relatively new having
only hit the scene in 2007 but quickly
became a fan favorite just like the
original Green Lantern this hero draws
his power from a magical ring pretty
cool right and did you know that the Red
Lantern characters actually have their
own antihero group called the Red
Lantern Corps that's right and this
group attempts to thwart the Green
Lantern at every turn an antihero this
malicious needs a pretty intense
doppelganger cat and we found just the
kitty we captured this cat looking
pretty intimidating showing its sharp
teeth and in the middle of a daunting
lurch
well the costume is nearly complete the
only thing missing is the Red Lanterns
magical ring I guess this Kitty is
powerless at the moment lucky for us
Wonder Woman okie-dokie someone sound
the cutie-pie alarm because this cat is
off the charts not only that which he's
also dressed as one of our favorite
superheroes Wonder Woman while many of
other superheroes were given their
powers through some sort of accident
Wonder Woman was actually given
superpowers on purpose she was first
sculpted out of clay by her mother Queen
Hippolyta and from there she was given
life by Aphrodite
Wonder Woman went on to be one of the
most inspirational and powerful
superheroes featured in DC Comics so
it's no wonder that this cat's owner
decided to dress this Kitty up as the
powerful lady herself this costume is so
well done we have to take a closer look
not only is she wearing the full Wonder
Woman outfit but she's also been given
an epic little crown so cute let us not
forget the cherry on top
since this cats also been equipped with
Wonder Woman's weapon of choice the
lasso of truth it looks like she's ready
to get out there and save the world
Superman watch out Superman it looks
like you may have finally met your match
that's right old Clark Kent better keep
Lois Lane
close because there's a new sheriff in
town we're talking of course about this
adorable kitty someone dressed this cat
up is one of the most classic
superheroes of all time Superman and boy
does he fit the role not only that but
there is something absolutely
mesmerizing about this picture it's
pretty perfect right before we get too
deep into it let's get a little
background on Superman did you know that
the Man of Steel has been around since
the early 30s the character was
originally created by two high school
students before being bought by DC
Comics this picture truly captures all
of the pride and responsibility that
Superman embodies I mean wouldn't you be
excited for this little cat to save you
from Lex Luthor we know we would Captain
America
one of the cornerstones of American
democracy is the right to freedom of
speech so we're going to use that
freedom to say that this might be one of
the cutest cats of the whole bunch not
only is the outfit superbly complete but
it also looks pretty comfortable too in
fact do you know where we might be able
to find a human-sized version of this
costume if you do please post a link in
the comments because we need to buy one
as soon as possible in the meantime
let's learn a little bit more about the
most patriotic superhero of them all
Captain America although the character
was created in the 40s Marvel actually
briefly discontinued the Captain America
comics during the 50s however it came
back with
and has continued to be a fan favorite
for over half a century you can tell
this cat owner is a true fan because
they even included Captain America's
strongest defense the indestructible
kitty cat shield Robin let us introduce
you to Robin Cat Boy Wonder Robin or
Dick Grayson as he's known to friends
doesn't always get the spotlight he
deserves yes as a true sidekick this
charming superhero often has to live in
the shadow of his friend Batman that is
why we were so excited to find this
picture here Batman and Robin are
presented side by side as squishy and
comfortable equals they could even be
twins
after seeing this picture we decided we
needed to find out more about Robin as
it turns out
Robin actually used to be his own
superhero named Nightwing pretty epic
right even cooler Robin comes from a
whole family of acrobats which is where
he gets his incredible agility and
aerial abilities reflecting on this
kitty cat Robin smushed up against the
very popular Batman
we think the Cat Boy Wonder certainly
deserves more love Thor throughout
ancient mythology cats and even kitties
have been worshipped feared and admired
in ancient Egyptian times in fact cats
were both domesticated and worshipped
throughout history cats have continued
to be popular figures in both pop
culture and the myths of various
cultures but cats aren't the only
mythological creatures on this list
that's right we're talking of course
about our next superhero Thor Thor who
is named after the Norse god of the same
name is the god of thunder scary
even more intimidating is the gigantic
hammer that he carries around with him
at all times we could actually use one
of those hammers right now since we've
got about a hundred cloves of garlic we
need to smash for tonight's dinner what
speaking of dinner isn't this Thor cat
just absolutely scrumptious whoever
decided to dress this cute little kitty
up his Thor and even give him his own
little hammer is our new hero Catwoman
okay this one seems a little too easy
but given that this cat is just so silly
looking we'll let the lack of
originality slide just this time whoever
decided to replicate cat woman's outfit
had the perfect cat for the job
this skinless kitty captures all that is
mysterious and alluring about Gotham
City's most-wanted burglar did you know
that Catwoman is one of Batman's biggest
love interests it seems like a match
made in heaven but for some reason they
just weren't able to make it work maybe
it's because Catwoman spends her time
committing
while Batman spends his trying to
prevent them either way we were just so
pleased to see Catwoman get what she
deserves a scary cat look-alike yes this
sneaky feline has it all from the full
leather suit to the rodent like tail the
only thing she's missing is her Batman
Iron Man what happens when you cross an
incredibly fierce superhero with a cat
and some leftover citrus fruits well you
get this Iron Man cat of course this is
probably the most creative use of a
lemon we've seen since our mom's chicken
piccata man that's a good chicken
piccata anyway we were delighted to see
one of our favorite superheroes Iron Man
get the feed line love he totally
deserves Iron Man's backstory is
heartwarming and inspiring billionaire
Tony Stark was on top of the world he
had several boats a tasteful wardrobe
and a spacious kitchen perfect for
hosting that is until he was kidnapped
received a chest injury and built
himself an incredibly powerful suit of
armor the suit allows him to fly way up
high in the sky produce powerful beams
of energy and gives him superhuman
strength it seems like this kittens
owner didn't have quite the resources to
replicate the whole costume so the lemon
mask will have to do Batman this
superhero goes by many names the Dark
Knight the Caped Crusader and even the
Smasher of evil we're talking about
Batman of course and you better believe
he's got his own cat look-alike Batman
is the ultimate superhero he's
altruistic highly-skilled and always
looking out for his city's back you may
see him cruising in a 68 Batmobile
hucking batarangs or just relaxing at
one of Gotham's amazing jazz bars either
way he's keeping the city safe from
wrongdoers like poison ivy The Joker and
two-face
the character was originally created in
1939 by DC Comics and quickly became a
fan favorite in fact Batman went on to
have his own television show as well as
many incredible movies pretty cool don't
you think what's also cool is this
beautiful little kitten dressed as the
Caped Crusader well he might be missing
the cape and the logo he's definitely
equipped with the Batman mask we all
know and love the Joker if you're prone
to nightmares you might want to look
away for this next cat because it's
definitely a little scary this next
character isn't quite a superhero but is
actually one of Batman's biggest nemesis
the Joker the Joker is the original
Batman villain and the character
actually
in the very first Batman comic which was
released in 1940 this clown like
wrongdoer has a warped sense of humor
and a ton of sinister tricks up his
sleeves that's right he's a total
prankster the Joker has appeared in
several of the Batman movies but one of
the most memorable appearances has to be
Heath Ledger's unforgettable portrayal
in The Dark Knight
we like to think that this performance
was the inspiration for this kiddie
version of the Joker
either way the cat's owner really nailed
the costume from the scary clown makeup
to the oversized tie this costume
totally crushes it spider-man
Mary Jane Watson eat your heart out
because there's a new Peter Parker in
town and unlike the real spider-man this
feline Spidey absolutely loves to cuddle
that's not your spidey senses tingling
that's your frozen heart slowly melting
and accepting this cat's love into your
life before we dive into this kittens
costume let's talk a little bit about
spider-man herself Peter Parker was just
an ordinary boy he played with trucks
built sand castles and even went to
school that is until he was bitten by a
radioactive spider gained superpowers
and decided to devote his life to
fighting crime with villains like the
Green Goblin Doctor Octopus and scorpion
around town he certainly has his hands
full no matter even the worst
supervillain is no match for the
incredible Spidey we think this cat
owner did an amazing job of capturing
all the pride confidence and nobility of
spider-man in this picture his
impeccable costume combined with the
sturdy posture makes this feline a dead
ringer is there a superhero you'd like
to see re-envisioned as a cat let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
[Music]